NBC News was reporting that Biden seeks
60 billion for Ukraine and aid for
Israel in1 100 billion funding request
we just heard uh President Joe Biden
speak and he said that we can't let
Petty partisan politics get in the way
of the responsibilities of a great
nation what responsibilities would that
be like defending the borders of this
nation or are you talking about
defending the borders of Ukraine because
what Joe Biden just did was he got on
camera and he just spat in your face I
that that I'm just that pisses me off
I'm sorry I just want to point out that
he did not name a dollar amount he said
he's going to put an emergency budget
Bill together but he's not telling you
how much because he you know it's going
to be astronomical on top of everything
else I think this is the most ridiculous
justification when he says well you guys
are wondering it's a direct shot at
anyone who's America first saying people
are asking why we should care about this
conflict well these regions be could
become more unstable regions that we
have messed with we have not helped
anyone in this conflict and now we're
going to go in and sacrifice American
troops for what can anyone tell me why I
should care about Ukraine I mean I know
a lot about what's going on Putin is a
direct comparison to Hamas the terrorist
organization which I'm sure is going to
go over really well in Russian State
media now well it shows where Joe
Biden's loyalties are he says proudly
that he walked through Kiev but where
was he for East Palestine the side of
the Biden Buddha judge trail dment that
he promised he would go to and still 8
months later 9 months later he helps at
Ukraine what about America I mean you
want to talk about A Wasteland and then
he singles out a family which look we
want everyone to be healthy safe no one
deserves any violence but he singles out
that family and not the shootings that
happen in Chicago or the violence that's
happening here in America and other
places and then and then furthermore the
thing that just gets me so hot is he
says he wants to protect Israel but how
do you protect Israel when you're
funding Iran you're funding Hamas you're
funding the attack that inspir HED this
against Israel and then you're playing
both sides at the same time and I just I
want to make it clear to everybody
that's listening you cannot stand with
Israel if you were funing Iran and Hamas
period and we need to see that Biden
announced $100 million for Gaza and the
West Bank there is no way that this
money does not find its way to Hamas
it's it's it's literally impossible they
are the military and governance of of
the Gaza Strip and as soon as stuff
comes in they walk up and say thank you
have a nice day those resources will go
to Hamas Hamas will whatever the aid may
be let's say it's Food they'll start
selling the food let's say it's water
pipes they'll turn those water pipes
into rockets and he knows this because
he said you know we're about to send
food and and medically necessary
whatever if it doesn't get stolen by
Hamas like he knows that even though we
can send Aid there's actually no way to
completely untangle the two so he's
playing both sides and he will fail
completely because he's trying to appeal
to the most Progressive part of his
voter demographic that supports
Palestine and he's trying to maintain
this we support Israel we're an ally
thing and they think this is an
impossible position so instead he just
Wast 15 minutes of Our Lives saying
nothing and warning us he's about to
deploy our troops and also spend another
hundreds of billions of dollars on
another entanglement that we shouldn't
be in they don't need to give to have a
presidential address to give money the
US gives money all the time when they
gave that what was it 12 million or
whatever in gender studies funding to
Pakistan the president did not come out
and say there are children who are
confused and they need funding care he
doesn't need to the point of a
presidential address is to get the
American people prepared for the
deployment announcement well this is
like the college tuition it's a Fool's
errand because as you mentioned earlier
we don't have a speaker so how could
they even get funding he's basically
pushing kicking the can down the road
and he's going to blame it and say well
I want to provide all this money I want
to to give it this is what we should be
doing but it's the house that is the
problem and he's just going to blame it
he's going to blame Republicans for this
entanglement that should we be going
into this because his his reasons were
not compelling to me people are people
are like should we what what what did we
gain from ating mcarthy and I'm like
paralysis I dig it I'm having a good
time and furthermore I want to make this
so clear and I said this while President
Joe Biden was tacking this did not
happen four years ago under President
Trump Putin did not invade Ukraine we
didn't have attacks of this size of
Hamas attacking Israel the fact of the
matter is our enemies are inspired by
the weak and feckless leadership of Joe
Biden and the Democratic party this was
not happening they are inspired by how
weak our government is yeah I think
you're totally right I mean he says that
America's a great nation and in that
sense we should have a great and strong
president who could steer the ship here
and it's obviously not Joe Biden no we
had no new Wars under Trump these people
don't care about saving Bloodshed we had
no new Wars under Trump Trump and then
they wanted to stop TR because they want
the wars and now they're not calling for
him back now they're calling for him the
only guy we had no new Wars under to be
in jail well don't worry uh Joe Biden's
going to create manufacturing jobs by
making us make military supplies yeah I
think the likelihood of uh us deployment
and and a large scale Warfare within the
next 12 months is like near 100% that's
why he's that's why he's giving this
address because it's not about we need
funding he could get the funding he
doesn't there's no there's no speaker
he's not sending anything to anybody
what he's doing is generating news the
word will go out to the American people
Ukraine Israel war that way in 6 months
when they're like a small group has been
dispatched to the area there's already
19,000 troops when they announc a small
contingent was deployed to the region
people will be like well of course we
we've been involved already MH well then
by the end of the year it's fulls scale
War why for one they want to be in war
they they they like the military
industrial complex needs the contracts
they like the contracts but there are
there are special interests that want
control of these regions and they know
that if Donald Trump gets elected they
they will not be able to get their Wars
so start the war now start the war now
so that when Trump gets elected he has
no choice but to navigate it and let's
really narrow this and hone in on what's
Happening and what's being said to every
gen Z that's listening right now to Tim
Cass to every Millennial to every young
person you are going to be the biggest
voting Block in 2024 and I want to say
it loudly and clearly to vote Democrat
at this point in time means to go to war
that gen Z will be drafted to fight Joe
Biden's Wars he wants that he wants
boots on the ground and again we did not
have that under the last previous
administration we had peace we didn't
have new Wars but it needs to be said
Joe Biden wants this war jenz needs to
understand this
one we haven't had the draft since
Vietnam because we haven't actually had
war on a massive scale like we did with
the during the Cold War with all the
proxy wars and with World War II after
World War I you basically have the
Soviet Union and the United States
dominating the world not engaging in
direct conflict but engaging in proxy
wars Vietnam is a really good example
then you have you know China and stuff a
communist influence is probably a better
way to put it after that we we we get
rid of the draft and and move towards
the the all volunteer military it's
basically an economic system of hey we
got a great job for you it pay as well
as's big bonuses but now that the
politics has bifurcated this country
you've got a lot of younger people who
are like I don't want to join the
military that's that's awful and and
recruitment levels are way way down
nobody wants to sign up but with the
involvement of the US in Ukraine and now
Israel I'm not saying boots on the
ground in Israel but our troops are just
we got 19,000 Personnel in the
Mediterranean 2,000 ready for deployment
if this does escalate into a larger war
that involves Russia or China they will
bring the draft back no question and it
is Gen Z who is first in line have fun
guys and I want the draft Dodger David
hog David hog will not be drafted just
understand this David hog is not going
to be drafted he is a wealthy privileged
political Elite and just like during the
old drafts he will be protected it's
going to be all these young dumb people
who believed him who voted for Democrats
who are the ones who are going to be
marching on the front line well and
remember ladies we have equality now
right and it's going to be women are
just as acceptable to be drafted as men
this is going be yes this is going to be
men and women z i abely going to break
my own legs not going to they'll put you
in some weird robot suit and be like
don't worry we got technology these days
you're good I mean no they they'll
they'll tell you don't worry you can
still work the computers or something MH
yep well I tell you I'm going to Penn
State University this next week the last
day to register to vote in Pennsylvania
is the 23rd and I have a large sign that
has Joe Biden is Uncle Sam saying Joe
Biden wants you to go to war and we need
to make this message mess clear to the
young people yeah voting for Joe Biden
is essentially voting for a draft award
I mean it's the highest probability
right this was not the case under
Republican leadership and they know that
they are old enough to know the
difference at this point well it was the
case under Republican leadership just I
should clarify just not Trump uh yep all
all Democrats Republicans they love war
war war what is it good for increasing
domestic manufacturing no I think I
think this is this moment where you'll
see a real um I I I'll be really curious
to see how your voter registration uh
situation goes because this is one thing
that I think Jen Z can finally
understand right even if they were
raised in the orange man bad and all
Republicans are whatever you know if
they are raised in even really
Progressive environments it's very clear
with that poignant God bless the troops
at the end of this message that Biden is
preparing everyone to go to war for his
bidding and I don't think even Jen Z
doesn't want to go thanks for watching
this clip from the timcast IRL podcast
hang out with us live Monday through
Friday at 8:00 p.m. and become a member
over at timcast.net